[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا
الكرام هل تعلمون ما هو الفرق بين السيسي
والسبسي يصيح كاتب
تونسي الفرق فقط
نقطع ابشروا يا اهل تونس
بطغيان
الخوالي هل تعلمون انه اذا فاز السبسي
ستكون تونس نسخه طبق الاصل عن مصر
السيسي الا تشاهدون ما يحدث في مصر حيث
سرقت الثوره عبر ديمقراطيه كاذبه يضيف
[موسيقى]
اخر الم يصبح زين العابدين بن علي على وشك
ان يكون زين العائدين
الى حكم تونس الا يعود الاستبداد الى تونس
من ابواب مشرعه وفوق البساط الاحمر بعد ان
هرب من
النافذه الم يخطئ الشعب التونسي خطا فادحا
انه تخلص من الافعى وترك
ابنائها الا تشي تصرفات اذناب بن علي
القادمين هذه المره عبر دهاليز الدوله
العميقه بانهم سينتقم شر انتقام من الشعب
التونسي هل صامت تونس دهرا كي تفطر على
رئيس خارج من القبر
بكفاله لكن في المقابل هل عاد جماعه بن
علي الى السلطه على ظهور الدبابات ام عبر
صناديق
الاقتراع اليس حريا بالجميع احترام خيارات
الشعب التونسي اليس من الاجحاف توصيف
الفائزين في الانتخابات بانهم اذنا ناب بن
علي اليس حركه سياسيه جديده افرزتها
الثوره كما افرزت غيرها من الحركات
والاحزاب
ثم ما العيب في عوده بعض الاحزاب القديمه
الى السلطه بمشاريع وتوجهات ديمقراطيه الم
يقل الزعيم السوفيتي الشهير لينين لا باس
ان نبني النظام الجديد بحجاره النظام
القديم اليس الشعب التونسي الواعي قادرا
بعد سنوات ان يزيح اي سلطه لا تلبي
طموحاته الثوريه اليس من حق نداء تونس ان
يجرب حظه في الحكم ديمقراطيا كما جرب
الاسلاميون من قبله ثم ازاحه الشعب بطريقه
ديمقراطيه حضاريه اسئله اطرحها على الهواء
مباشره هنا في الاستوديو على الاعلامي
التونسي واحد انصار المرشح منصف المرزوقي
السيد سليم بوخذير وعبر الاقمار الصناعيه
من تونس على الاعلامي الصحفي السيد حسن بن
عثمان نبدا نقاش بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج
الاتجاه المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على
موضوع هذه الحلقه هل تعتقد ان الاستبداد
قد يعود الى تونس من بوابه الديمقراطيه 87
عفوا
78.2 نعم
21.8 لا سيد ابو خذر لو بدات معك هذه
النتيجه ما الذي يجعل هذه النسبه الهائله
حوالي 80% من هذه الشريحه على الاقل تعتقد
ان الاستبداد عائد الى تونس حرب من الباب
ثم يعود من النافذه ثم على بساط احمر
وبطريقه مشروعه هذه المره يعني التونسيون
بعد ثلاث سنوات الان من من اسقاط نظام بن
علي من اسقاط بن علي صاروا يعون تماما من
خلال المحصله على الارض هو اننا لم نتخلص
فقط من الافعى لم نحصل فقط حتى على هذا
المطلب يعني نحن تخلصنا من راس الافعى اما
الافعى نفسها وليس ابنائها بقيت في تونس
راسها اختفى في السعوديه لكن بق لها رؤوس
اخرى لم نكن نعرفها والان الثوره المضاده
حققت على الارض اكثر من مكسب لصالحها فنحن
راينا احكام الثوره المضاده لصالح الثوره
المضاده تحققت كثير من المكاسب اولها ان
هناك احباط من الاحكام القضائيه الصادره
ضد قتله الشهداء اولها عوده النظام القديم
بحزب علني بحزب علني وكانه خيانه للحكم
القضائي الصادر ضد حزب التجمع التوري
الديمقراطي من خلال هذا الكيان الذي اسمه
نداء تونس ومن خلال كيانات اخرى ترتدي نفس
الجلبان من الذي سمح له بالعوده قانونيا
بهذه الطريقه يعني الخلل هو ان الثوره
معسكر الثوره انتج احزاب لم تكن منضبطه مع
استحقاق الثوره وهذه فاتوره تدفعها يدفعها
تدفعها الترويكا ليس من رصيدها وانما من
رصيد الشعب التونسي لانهم هم مسؤولين عن
عوده هؤلاء وكذلك احزاب اخرى لم تكن في
الترويكا كانت الى جانب معسكر الثوره مدت
الايادي امام الستارت وخلف الستارت الى
الثوره المضاده الى بقايا التجمع دستور
الديمقراطي فوقع اغرائهم والان يعود من
خلال المال الفاسد من خلال بعض وسائل
الاعلام ال الفاسد المال الفاسد موجود في
تونس موجود بيوفر المال الفاسد ونحن لم
نستعد المال المنهوب المال المنهوب في جزء
كبير منها كان في الداخل وبقي في الداخل
هؤلاء الذين اكلوا من خيراتنا بغير حق
ونهبوا العام هو موجودين في الداخل وبعضهم
انجز احزاب وراينا المال السياسي الفاسد
في في في في الانتخابات التشريعيه
والرئاسه يعني يجوب الاسواق وهذا المال
السياسي الفاسد صنع في جزء منه رجح الكفه
لصالح عوده النظام القديم والتونسيون
يصوتون او الملاحظون يصوتون ب 78% لان
الاشارات اولا ليس الظام فقط عاد وانما
عاد بمشاريعه القديمه هم يخفون خطابهم
الحقيقي لكن هناك انفلاتات دكتور فيصل بين
الفينه والاخرى انا اذكرك ان الباجي
السبسي هذا خرج في اذاعه موزايك وهو راديو
هام في تونس وقال انه لا يعجبه قانون
العداله الانتقاليه قال ايضا في تصريح اخر
انه يجب مراجعه هيئه الكرامه الحقيقه
والكرامه هذا الباجي سبسي خرج واهان
الاعلاميين اكثر من مره كيف تريدني وانت
تدعي الديمقراطيه وانت تهين اهم عصب
للديمقراطيه وهو حرمه الاعلام وكرامه
الصحف وكرامه المهنه الصحفيه منذ ايام فقط
معناها اطلق عباره بذيئه وغير محترمه زميل
صحفي من قناه المتوسط قبلها قبلها خرج
ووصف الناخب التونسي كيف رييد ان نقتنع
انك مؤمن بالديمقراطيه وانت تصنف اكثر من
مليون تونسي بانهم ارهابيين وانهم سلفين
هذه اهانه للشعب التونسي وليس اهان لهذا
الجزء فقط من الناخبين هؤلاء غير
ديمقراطيين لو كان الباجي السبسي
ديمقراطيا لقبل بسنه وقبل بعو هذا رجل
اعترف بالتزوير هذا رجل رفض الاعتذار عن
عذبات اليوسفيين يعني ناس كلاتها الحافر
في سجون في سجون بورقيبه وكان مدير الامن
وقتها الباجي السبسي وكان بعد ذلك وزير
الداخليه وتعذب في عهد ايضا رفاقنا من
الحركه الاسريه من حركه برسبكتيف هؤلاء
تربوا في حضن الاحاديه لو كان يوم
بالديمقراطيه السمسي لكان قبل بوعوده التي
ذكرها حتى في قناه الجزيره لاحمد منصور
قال زيني انا يكفيني انا اخذت تناوبت
وساغار بعد رئاسه الحكومه المؤقته والان
يعود يعود لانه غير قابل لانه محبين
للكرسي ومحبين لثروات ومحبين لان كنا
انصاف مواطنين وحتى حين نعطي راينا نوصف
باننا ارهابيين لانهم ينظرون عن ان صاف
تونسيين وان تونس لهم كلا تونس لنا تونس
لشبابها تونس لا تقبل بشخص منتهي الصلحيه
اعلنوها قادتهم قادتهم هذا عمر اصحابه
ونور الدين بتيش اعلن وانا رجل مريض حتى
بالعين المجرده حتى بالعين المجرده يا
دكتور فيصل حين نشاهده نشاهد تصريحات نجد
رجل ينسى هذا رجل نحن رفضنا الرئاسه مدى
الحياه فاتان مدى الحياه شخصيا اتاه مدى
الحياه ويريد ان يتمدد علينا نحن نرفض هذا
هذه ثوره شباب هذه ثوره حقوق وحريات وهذا
الرجل لا علاقته بالحقوق والحريات لا يمكن
بناء مناخ ديمقراطي الا فرسان الديمقراطيه
هذا ليس فارس من فرسان الديمقراطيه هذا
كان عدوها هذا يوم 17 جوان دكتور فيصل
2009 حين كان منافسه الدكتور منسف مرزوقي
محاصرا مهجرات فع عن تونس في الخارج وكنت
انا محاصر بالداخل وباقي رفاقنا في الحركه
الديمقراطيه خرج في صحيفه الشروق وقال ان
بن علي خيارنا الاوحد كيف تريدني ان
استبدل بن علي في سن ال0 ببن علي في سن 90
كلاهما واحد يعني الرجل الاكبر حتى من
الاستاذه صباح الشحروره رحمه الله السبسي
اكبر من
صباح السبسي اكبر من صباح اكبر من عبد
الحليم حافظ طيب ماشي عبد الحليم حافظ
اللي انا عمري 42 سنه معناها ولم لم اكن
حيا لم اكن اعي حين كان هو يغني تصور انه
هو اكبر منه كيف تريدني ان اثق انا ككه
تونسي او وراي الشباب في مستقبل تونس على
يد رجل عمره 90 سنه اي مستقبل هذا ح اي
جميل جدا نطرح هذا السؤال على السيد حسن
بن عثمان في في تونس سيد حسن بن عثمان
اريد ان ترد على هذه الشري
التي تعتقد يعني اكثر من 78% من هذه
الشريحه يقولون ان الاستبداد بدا يعود الى
تونس من اوسع ابوابه او اذا صح التعبير
كيف
ترد انا اولا يعني استاذ فيصل اريد ان
احييك واحيي اهلنا في قطر وفي
الخليج ويعني انبه من البدايه انه انا
انسان مستقل لست كما اخونا المناضل
والرفيق سليم
بوخذير واريد ان انبه انه يعني مقدمتك يا
فيصل المشحونه بالبغضاء
وتهييج وتجييش الشعب التونسي هذه تخصك اما
بخصوص
هذه ما تريد ان توحي به انه هذه شريحه و
شريحه منخفضه او سافره هذه مساله يعني
لابد ان تبرهن عليها انت
شخصيا لابد وايضا لابد ان نفسر لاخوتنا
العرب حتى لا نست لا نستغرب ولا نستحم
عقلهم انه ما حدث في تونس ثوره وثوره
متواصله بل فهي ثوره غيرت في مفهوم الثوره
نفسه وغيرت ايضا في معطيات وفي فهمنا
والثوره التي لا تغير
في مفاهيم والافكار فهس بثوره وتعرف جيدا
ويعرف ايضا يعني زميلنا سليم انه الثوره
هذيه كان قائدها ابو القاسم الشابي كان
شاب مات عمره 25 سنه وانجز منجزا شعريا
مذهلا واستثنائيا بلا مثيل ونحن نعيش الان
في جانب اخر من اسطوره الثوره التونسيه عن
طريق شخص عجوز يجدد شباب الثوره من حيث لا
تدرون ردوا بالكم يعني تشعلوا الفتين
النار بهذه الطريقه انما يعني حين يتكلم
السيد سم بوخذير ماذا يقول ما هو الاخير
يعني يعني رفاق رفاق رفاق في الاخير شن
قضيته هو يعني نحنا قلنا انه هذه الثوره
جات الاخوان جيه في تونس الاخوان المسلمين
عن طريق يعني حركتهم
النهضه تملكوا الحكم توانس عام 2011 23
اكتوبر 2011 يعني ينتخبهم التوانسه وسلمهم
الباجي قاد السبسي الحكومه وك كان يعني
باجي قد السبسي كان رئيس حكومه مؤقت على
القلوب وكان انسان خفيف على القلوب يعني
عنين انتهت عهدته باشهر قليله سلم العهده
وكان الشعب التونسي قد انتخب هذه المجموعه
ما نسموه نحن الترويكا او التتريك هؤلاء
الذين رغبوا ان يتركوا الشعب تونس تتريك
هنا بالمعين لان تونس كانت مستعم ل تركيا
ولا نريد ان يعني الحقيقه يعني نثير نعاره
الماضي انما سلموا له الحكم من اجل سنه
فقط فتواصل حكمه الى حد الان اليوم نحنا
في تونس هذا اليوم الذي نتكلم فيه ينعقد
مجلس الامه او مجلس الشعب او مجلس
النواب يعني بعد كم من عام بعد ثلاث سنوات
والشعب التونسي خضع في ا الناس الرئيس
الغنوشي ماذا قال
قال لقد كان يعني التزاما اخلاقيا وم
التزاما قانونيا او دستوريا يعني ونحن
نذكر هذا الرجل انه الامه التي بلا اخلاق
سع نحن من دين سيدنا محمد عليه الصلاه
والسلام جاء لاتمام مكارم الاخلاق وهؤلاء
اثبتوا انه لا اخلاق لهم ولذلك الشعب
التونسي حين يختار الباجي قال سدسي لماذا
ي اختاره اختاره لانه رفع شعار الصدق في
القول والاخلاص في العمل وقد اخلص في قوله
وصدق في عمله في كل م قان ولا تفضل سلم
بوخذير اللي بحذاك ويحاسبني على هذا سلام
الله عليكم اهلا وسهلا كيف ترد يا حسن
منين مش نبد لك يعني فل تحكي فيه من اين
سابدا ايا اولا نحب يجاوبني سي حسن بن
عثمان راحتك خذ راحتك
يا من عين الباجي يد السبسي هذا رئيسا
للحكومه في بعد الثوره ثانيا انا كي قلت
انا غير مستقل في علاقتي بالحمله
الانتخابيه وعلت موقفي مساند الكتور
خمجه الان المواجه الان قلت صف المرزوقي
كانت ل الشجاعه كاعي مستقل عن الاحزاب
وصحفي وكاتب انتنت مستقل انت غير مستقل
انت مسدج السبسي لانه يمثل المنظومه انت
كنت فيها يا حسن هذ الحقيقه انت تدافع عن
المنظومه
المع
رف حمله انتخابيه انك مستقل وتلمع صوره
احد المرشحين فانت مشارك عمليا في وافتخر
بذلك تونس وانت تعرف انه انا كاتب وتعرفني
كاتب حر طيب سيد سليم سد سليم سيد سليم بس
خلينا ما نشخص الموضوع انا اريد انا بس
دقيقه بس دقيقه بس دقيقه بس دقيقه بس
دقيقه من شخص الموضوع سيدل نحن
اريدك الكلام الان الكلام الان خليني اكم
لك سؤال الكلام الان انه يا اهل تونس
ابشروا بطغيان جديد ستتم من خلاله على
الطغيان هذا هو اليس في هذا الكلام الكثير
من المبالغه انا اريد ان اسالك سؤالا اه
انت تقول انه كل مظاهر الاستبداد القديم
عادت كل اذناب النظام القديم بداوا يعودون
وبدات تعطيني الكثير من الامثله هل جاء
هذا العهد الجديد على ظهور الدبابات ام
جاء عبر صناديق دي ق الاقتراع لماذا لا
نحترم اراده الناخبين التونسيين بدل القول
ان الاستبداد سيعود يا اخي حق التونسيين
يختاروا زعيط محنش شو دخلك انت من الذي لا
يحترم ايرادات التونسيين نحن نحترم رادات
التونسيين نحن قبلنا بنتائج التشريعيات
كتونس من كل الاطياف من كل الاطياف التي
كانت مناضله قبل 14 جانفي هذه الاطياف
قبلت بالانتخابات لكن احد الاطياف الصانعه
اللي هو من و من رحم النظام القديم هو
نداء تونس سمسي لم يعترف بالنتائج الدور
الاول واعتبر مليون واج تونسي اللي
انتخبوا الدكتور منصف المرزوقي ارهابيين
وسلفيين هم لا يحترمون لانهم هم اوفياء
لخطابهم اوفياء للبيت الذي خرجوا منه
البيت الدكتاتوري البيت الاحادي البيت
الكلاني البيت الشمولي نحصل بعد ال اجبني
على
السؤال كيف جاؤوا الى كيف جاؤوا الى
البرلمان وكيف جاؤوا الى الرئاسه حسب
النتائج الاخيره جاوا بالصندوق بالصندوق
وم العيب في الصندوق نحن انت ديمقراطي
اليس كل الديمقراطيين يناضلون من اجل
شفافيه ال احترام نتائج الصندوق نحن
احترمنا النتائج يا دكتور فيصل احترمنا
النتائج والان البرلمان التونسي هو تشكيله
واسعه من كل الاطياف فيها حزب التجمع
العائد باغلبيه لكن هناك جزء ثاني فيه
الطرف الاخر لكن انا اريد ان اوضح فكره هو
ان شفافيه الصندوق لا تعني شفافيه
الانتخابات رغم اني قبلت بالنتائج شفافيه
الصندوق هي شفافيه مرحله واحده في
الانتخابات هناك مراحل اخرى صندوق مساله
تتويج للعمليه الانتخابيه هناك تزوير
استباقي للايرادات هناك تزوير اعلامي
بالتحرش بالناس خارج المكاتب الهيئه
المستقله للانتخابات هذه يا استاذ فيصل
قبلت بان يكون مراقبها داخل المراكز فقط
ليس خارجها كان هناك مال سياسي يجوب اعطيك
دليلا على على التزوير في تونس التزكيات
هذا السيد الباجي قاد السبسي صاحب 90 سنه
و 89 سنه اعتقد عمره هذا الرجل صعد الى
المرتبه الى 27 قائمه 27 ضمن مرشحي
الرئاسه بتكي
بالتكييفات مزوره ونشرت هذا في صفحتها
الرسميه وحاله جزء من الموضوع الى القضاء
لكن هذه الهيئه اعطتهم الحق في الترشح رغم
اقرارها بان التزكيات مزوره طيب اذا حكم
القضاء الان بانه هذا الباجي السبسي
تزكيته مزوره كيف سنفعل حين يصبح رئيس كيف
نقبل يعني هناك جانب من العمليه
الانتخابيه كان فييه انحرافات وهذه
الانحرافات لا يمكن قب والان هناك محاوله
لارسال رسائل انه هذه فزاعات نحن لم تعد
مظاهر الاستبداد تماما نحن على خوفا من
عودتها ولنا مؤشرات على ذلك اعطيك مثال
نحن كصحفي نقرا المشاهد دكتور فيصل الان
شبكه التواصل اسمها الفيسبوك الجدار كتبنا
على الجدار يعني الكتابه على الجدار هي
اشرف شيء يمكن ان يفعل في
الديمقراطيات كنا نحاسب في عاد بن علي على
الكتاب الكتاب على الورق على كل ما هو
يعني يعني مضمون نكتب عليه الان يعتقل
انسان كتب عباره دجاج العباره الشهريه
العباره الشعريه الراقيه الجميله للثوره
التونسيه كتبها فوقع اعتقاله في مدينه
اسمها جرور الان يعود ياتي ياتي الباجي
سبسي ويصف صحافي ويقول له هذه الكلمه
هؤلاء لن يكون اوفي نحن نخاف حين يكون لنا
رئيس واحد رئيس للحكومه ورئيس سنكون في مد
الحزب الواحد الثوره قامت على هؤلاء
الثوره قامت على هذه الممارسات وليس على
الاشخاص هؤلاء حين يغيروا كيف سيغير اذا
حققنا ضمانات ونتوجه لشعبنا اخر فرصه لك
لضمان الحقوق والحريات لان مدخلك الحقيقي
لتونس الجديده هو انك ما تطلعش مع احترامي
للباجي السبسي ماطلعش رئيس الحزب الحاكم
هو رئيس جمهوريتك اللي عمره 90 سنه لن
يحترمك وقتها هو قاللكم ماك عا قاللكم
القناصه اللي قلتله التوانسه اللي ض حيانا
معناها مازال دماهم على اسفلت قاللكم راهم
اشاعه غدا سيقول لكجي السبسي الديمقراطيه
اشاعه وكرامتك اشاعه وتونس كلها اشاعه ما
تصدقوهم الان الحل المص مرزوقي له اخطاء
انا مختلف معه وتعرفوا انتب ياتي معه
التوجه الشعبي المص المرزوقي يكون حامل
الحريات وانتظروا مفاجات سيكون الفريق
الديمقراطي في تونس سيكون حم ونجيب الشابي
ومص كلهم الى جانب ترشيح دكتور مرسم
مرزوقي مع مراجعه اخطائ جم جدا جميل جدا
سيدد حسن انت استبقت الجميع في 13 جانوار
اعتقد 2011 عندما قلت
ان بن علي 14 14 14 طيب 14 ان بن علي
انتهى طيب هذا الكلام كيف انتهى بن علي
طيب انا بدي اسالك نحن لماذا لا نقيس
التجربه التونسيه على تجارب تاريخيه اخرى
انظر ماذا حدث في مصر انظر ماذا حدث ق قبل
مصر في رومانيا مع تشاو سيسكو في
1989 رومانيا تشاو سيسكو اطلقوا النار
عليه وعلى زوجته لكن الثوره الرومانيه لم
تنجح جاء اليسكو وحكم بعده س سنوات وسنوات
ومارس الارهاب وقتل وذبح باسم الديمقراطيه
نفس الذي حصل في رومانيا يحصل الان في
تونس باسم الديمقراطيه وباسم كل هذه
الاكاذيب هل فطر يعني هل صام الشعب
التونسي دهرا كي يفطر على واحد قال لك
اكبر من صباح بع سنوات يا زلمه بخمس سنوات
بس نجم نجاوبك ها تفضل انا عارف يا دكتور
اللي انت يعني مرشح المرزوقي رشحه
المرزوقي مش هذا الموضوع انما انا يدي ان
انبه قليلا لقضيه
ديقاج واذكر يعني ضيفك الرفيق المناضل
واقوله فيق يا رفيق
يهديك لسك تعرف ايش معناه حمادي الجبالي
حمادي الجبالي 2012 قال ديقاج انساها ولكن
الحمد لله الشعب التونسي عمل لله ديقاج و
نحاه
انا مش حدخل معك انا تعرف يا سليم احي
الغوغاء وتعجبني
الغوغاء مش هذا موضوعي انما انا اريد ان
احيي مصر واحيي السيسي ذلك الرجل العظيم
الذي انقذ مصر من الخساب كانت بين عشيه
وضحاء مصر تكاد تكون مصران مصر قبطيه و
مصر اخوانيه اخوان مسلمين
ولذا ماذا اصبحت مصر هل اصبحت المانيه هل
اصبحت ديمقراطيه يا حسن مصر هل انه
الحريات المقموعه في مصر دليل انها دوله
ديمقراطيه ما الديمقراطيه لم تكن حقوق
الانسان هل يجوز ان نقول العلمانيه
والديمقراطيه
حقل اسمع اتركني اتركني
احترم الناس لا تدفعني لاشم اخرين عن
طريقك وعندي قدره على هذ ذلك رد بالك يا
سليم رد بالي من شنو تفضل لا لا كيف ترد
عليه يعني هذا الرجل رد بالك
تتركني على قطر بال ل قطر هذا لعب على
حكيه قطر وما
قطرين مش عاوزين مش عاوزين نهرب من
الموضوع يا سيدي هلق الموضوع موضوعي
موضوعي تونس وموضوعي الخوف من عوده الا من
النهه دافع عن الهه الاسلامين انا ادافع
عن
مشروع يا سيد حسن يا سيد حسن لماذا لا
تدافع لماذا لا تدافع لماذا لا تدافع
عن انفي لي موضوع الاستبداد وعوده
الاستبداد سالتك انا انت قلت بالحرف
الواحد انه ب
يا اخي
اماهير
ح
بالقانون يمكن تجمع
و بالم
التونسي مستحيل يرجع نحن الان نعيش في
التجربه يعني نشرحها اجراح وهي جديده
تماما على الذهن العربي والاسلامي وكونوا
على يقين نحن ندعو اخوتنا الخليجيين
والجزيره سبق ان ساهمت معنا في هذا الحراك
العظيم عليها ان لا تنقب علينا ولا ت زدنا
را هذا لا يليق بها ولا يليق بقطر ولا
بالقطرين سيدي يا سيدي يا سيدي يا سيدي
دقيقه يا سيدي يا سيدي يا سيدي يا يا
استاذ حسن هلك انت وين موجود هلك انت وين
موجود انت موجود على شاشه الجزيره لتقول
رايك وتدافع عن رايك وعن كل هذا الكلام
ليش بلشت تلف اللي انا عم بسالك سؤال محدد
انا عم بسالك سؤال محدد قل لي انه
الاستبداد لن يعود قل لي الاستبداد لن
يعود انا اجبتك انا اجبتك اجابه محده ما
في مستحيل يا فيصل انا اتقلك اذا كان انت
يا سي يا فيصل اسمعني حبيبي اسمعني انا
اطمئنك قاله مستحيل نحن الان تجاوزنا
موضوع معين هذا اللي بحذاك يدافع على شخص
شخص هذا الشخص يعني سم يا رئيس مؤقت ليس
مؤقت في القانون رئيس منتخب لا هو رئيس
منتخب غصبا عنكم هو رئيس منتخب قانون هذا
وحاولوا تور الحقي وغصبا عنكم الحقيقه
الواضح انه التجمع ل يحل لا رئيس منتخب
حين
تسليم هو رئيس هو رئيس الدوله هو رئيس
الدوله الشرعي جاب انقلاب المصف المرزوقي
منصف المرزوقي في هذا المكان اللي انت
تعتبره غيرك مقد هذا الاتجاه هو اللي دافع
على تونس لم يكن هناك الباجي قا السبسي
وقتها حين كان المنصف مرزوقي في هذا
المنبر بالذات وفي مرات متوالي يدافع عن
شعبه ويدفع الفواتير الباهظه هو خليني لم
يك خل المهم المهم انه هو رئيس شرعي الان
الى غايه ان يسلم اعترف به هو رئيس شرعي
ما حدث اليوم لا يستد
رئيس موضوعي مش موضوعي
مو يا اخي سيد حسن مش هذا موضوعي هذا
موضوعي بس سيد سليم سيد سليم السيد حسن
قال كلاما انتم تهول الامور انتم تستخدمون
النظام القديم
كبعبلا كل هذه الامور انتهت لا يمكن ان
يعود النظام القديم الاحزاب الجديده
الاحزاب الجديده التي تتنافس على السلطه
افرزتها الثوره ولا تعود ي حزب او عهد
سابق او حرس قديم كيف ترد اول بعبع هو ما
يقال على ان مساندي الدكتور منصف المرزوقي
هم من السلفيين ومن النهضويين وهذا غير
حقيقي ان كان هناك مرشح ديمقراطي في تونس
ويدافع عن الديمقراطيه فهو الدكتور مصم
المرزوقي كان لنا فريق من المرشحين في
الدور الاول بينهم الرفيق حم الامامي
ونجيب الشابي ومصطفى جعفر والكيلاني
المرزوقي الان اثمر الدور الثاني عن ترشيح
مرشح للديمقراطيه في تونس وهناك ما يثبت
انه مرشح للديمقراطيه ومرشح للمنظومه
القديمه التجمع يا استاذ فيصل ليس جدران
وابواب وشبابيك التجمع هو كيان بشري هو
منظومه كامله هذا التجمع حل على الورق حل
الجدران والابواب والشبابيك لكن رموزه
بقوا في حزب هذا نداء تونس بتاع السبسي
هذا كان امين عام التجمع مستشارا في حزب
السبسي هناك قيادات الان في البرلمان
التونس تسي ضمن اكثر من 50% من مرشحين
نداء تونس هما كانوا قيادات في التجمع
السوري الديمقراطي التجمع لم يكون اسماء
وشكل كان مضمونا وهذا المضمون يعبر عنه
اليوم الباجي سبسي من خلال تصريحاته وهي
ليست زلات بلسان بالمناسبه هي تصريحات
الرجل اتال يتراجع عن قانون العداله
الانتقاليه الرجل يصف من ينتخب طرفا اخر
بالارهابيين الرجل لا يحترم حريه الصحافه
هذا رجل تربى هذا رجل لا يريد الاعتذار
قلت لكنه لا يريد حتى اعتراف نحن لم
نحاسبهم بعد 14 لم نحاسبهم بعد 14 يناير
قلنا على الاقل يعني تكون هناك عداله
انتقاليه لا تذهب الى الانقام لكن حتى
الاعتذار لم يعتذروا يعني هناك فريق منهم
الان المنظومه ليست اسماء هي هي كيان كامل
موجود وهذا الكيان تجسم في حزب اسمه نداء
تونس له نفس الاليات ونفس الوسائل وهذا
الحزب اخذ البرلمان واخذ رئاسه الحكومه لو
كانوا هؤلاء ديمقراط هل يقبلون بمرشح
بمرشح يعني بلغ 90 سنه حين نقول ان ان
مظاهر الاستبداد عادت نحن نبالغ لكن ليس
بعب عن مظاهر العوده اليه موجوده مظاهر
انيه العوده اليه موجوده من خلال
تصريحاتهم احد قياداتهم صرح انه يريد حل
الاحزاب السياسيه هناك حمله كبرى هناك
افتكاك للاعلام هل تعلم انت ان هناك قنوات
بعينها تقوم ليلا نهارا بالدعايه لشخص احد
المرشحين يعني علنا هذه الكينه قديمه وهذه
الكينه يقع تفكيكها والخطا ان لا يدافع عن
النهضه ولا على الاسلاميين يا يا حسن وهال
البعب يحب ركبوه زاد دكتور مرزوقي ورفاقه
انه الاسلاميين وال النهضويين انا اقول لك
انه انه المخطئ في ذلك هو النهضه وحكومه
النهضه الاولى والثانيه هذه حقيقه لم تكن
ب فتح صفحات الماضي ولذلك راينا رجلا يريد
ان يعري نفسه علينا هل هذا ديمقراطي هذا
قمه الاستبداد هذه لما يفعلها ابن علي قام
قال ساعر عليكم نفسي امام الجماهير وفي
الشاشات اتا وقال عباره غير محترمه في حق
صحفي لان وجه له سؤال كيف تريدني ان اثق
في هذا الرجل الذي ينسى هذا الرجل الذي
يريد ان يتخيل نفس مصاب مصاب بمرض
الزهايمر يعني بالخرف يعني لا لا لا اقول
هذا اقول انه انه نسي ان هناك ثوره هو
ممكن اكثر الله اعلم يعني انا لست طبيبا
لكن قياداته القريبه منه اكدت انه مريض
كيف تريدني ان اثق في انه الاستبداد وهذه
اجابتي على سؤالك لا يعود وانا ارى خطاب
الماضي يعود خطاب الماضي هذا الرجل يذهب
الى الى اتهام الناس بانهم ارهابيين ويذهب
الى محاوله تعطيل قانون العداله
الانتقاليه وياتي اليوم وصرح ما منذ منذ
شهر اعتقد بمحاوله التراجع عن هيئه
الحقيقه والكرامه هذا الرجل لا تهمه
المحاسبه لا يريد ان يعود مالنا ليست لهم
مقاربات ثوريه هؤلاء لا يريدون ان يتحدثوا
عن ثوره يريدون اعاده التجمع وهذا خطابهم
واضح وكل قياداتهم اقصائيه وهذه العوده
الى محاوله حل الاحزاب ومعاقبه من كتب
ديغاج في جرور كلها علامات تدل على ان
هؤلاء سيعيدون منظومه الماضي اذا نحن لم
نتصدى لهم المنقذ الحالي العنصر الذي ينقذ
الوضع الحالي هو امكانيه انتخاب الدكتور
منصف مرزوقي هذه الامكانيه ستصنع التوازن
نحن لن نقصي حقيقه في المشهد وهي انهم
وصلوا بالصندوق في جانب و فل يشكلوا حكومه
هذا حقهم نحن نريد تونس للجميع لا نريد
اقصا احد لكن فل يكن هناك توازنا حين
يعودون الى فكره ان يكون رئيس الجمهوريه
ورئيس الحكومه نفس الحزب ورئيس البرلمان
فهذه هي الاحاديه بعينها وهذه اسم عوده
الحزب الواحد كان اسمه تجمعا ولا بدل اسمه
اصبح موسى الحاج او الحاج موسى كلها واحد
المهم اننا سن نعيش في حكم فردي وهذا
الحكم الفردي ل لن يكرس الا القمع الحريات
وقد بدات نيته في ذلك جميل جدا سيد حسن
اسك سؤال الا تعتقد ان كل بلدان الثورات
التي سمحت للفلول او للحرس القديم بان
يبقى ويشارك وينافس على السلطه ارتكبت خطا
فادحا لماذا لم تتعلم من ثورات التاريخ
التي نجحت لماذا لم تتعلم من الثوره
الفرنسيه التي كانت تقيم محاكمات ميدانيه
للحرس القديم يعني على الماشي وانت ماشي
لماذا لم تتعلم من الثوره الروسيه هل كانت
الثوره الروسيه لتنجح لولا انها اجتزت
جذور جذور الانظمه القديمه هل تتذكر ماذا
فعل الخميني بمعارضيه وببقا الشاه ذهب الى
فرنسا ليغت لهم ذهب الى كل مكان الم يكن
من الخطا قبول هذا العهد القديم بان يعود
عبر دهاليز دهاليز الدوله العميقه ب بش
يعني الخطا الفادح انهم سمحوا لهؤلاء
العجائز ان يعودوا الى السلطه كيف ترد يا
اخي مش بالضروره تطولي يا ولدي اسمعني انا
سمعتك تفضل وانت انا سمعتك
تفضل ح لا انت ه اسمع في يا سيد سيد حسن
سيد حسن لا تاخذني بس هو هو هو لا تاخذني
بالصوت هون هون سيد حسن احترم احترم
الجميع ما تبلش توزع كلام طالع نازل خلص
انا بخلص سؤال انت بتجاوب اوكي جاوب ما
تقول لي
اسكت تفضل معلش في الحاله يا حسن تفضل
اوكي حبيبي اوكي ماشي ماشي يا دكتور ماشي
تفضل اذا يعني انا منقول لك اريد ان اقول
لك يا فيصل يا دكتور يا دكتور انما
التفاهه تتعلق بتوافه الامور هذا السيد
المرزوقي الذي سمي ترتو في تونس وضبط اسمه
في معجم لاروس الفرنسي ك ترتور قال دعا
انه للمشق والمقاس وقطع الرؤوس
علي كان سيد طرطور الاكبر بن علي زين مرصف
المرزوقي التاريخ مشور التاريخ المرزوقي
ولا طرطور كان كان كان مدافع على الشعب
التونسي ضد طرطور الاكبر زين العابدين بن
علي هو المنصف المرزوقي من اول مسيرته
لاخر مسيرته تو الان الرجل هذا اللي احترم
حريات التعبير
وس كل
حال
حان اسمه هوش في الحانه احسن تذكر انه
احنا في استوديو الان مش في الحانه رجاء
بالله انا حانه حانه ماذا طيب ايها
الابله وصفات سيد حسن سيد حسن يا ريت
تجاوبني سيد حسن سيد حسن يا ريت تجاوبني
على سؤالي سيد حسن لو تكرمت لو تكرمت سيدي
انا سالتك سؤال ارجوك تجاوبني عليه انه
كان الخطا في كل الثورات العربيه التي لم
تجت العمي من اصولها هذا نحن زين العابدين
اصبح زين العائدين كما يقول بعض
الساخرين كف ترد انت كنت رئيس تحرير
الحياه الثقافيه ولا
لا اسمعن طبعا تفضل سيضل سنوات رس تحر
الحيا
الثقافيه اعرف عمي ه البلاد تفضل لعله قال
السيد بحك ماشي البلاد انما تونس هذه
البلاد
الصغيره تقريبا 10 مليون بشر نعرفوا بعضنا
فردا فردا تفضل تفضل جاوبني على السؤال
بتاعي لو تكرم من هو الملوث ومن هو النذل
ومن هو الساق اسمعني يا فيصل تفضل يا سيدي
تفضل
تفضل يافضل يا سيفضل نحن يعني لابد انتم
نحن نقول بالطريقه التونسيه ما نعرفوه
بقري الا بالكرشه
معناه ما نعرفوها ثوره الا يعني ان تسيل
دماء حالا الحمد لله ثوره تونسيه ثوره
يايسمين وما فيهاش دماء وهذا لعله يغي بعض
الثورين من امثالكم يا سيدي في حين ان صار
تونسيه من فضل الله عليها انه ربي يسترها
ويعني كانت امورها مقتصده في العنف
والدم يعني هي خلعت نظام وخلعت رئيس وخلعت
حزب حاكم والان تخذ يعني تجربه ديمقراطيه
استثنائيه لنا حزب النهضه عنده 9 69%
واليوم نحن نعم في يعني برلمان جديد ونحن
نتامل على الله ان تكون تجربتنا هديه
للعرب لاخواننا ان ان نخرج من هذه الاحقاد
والعنف المجاني والدموي اللي يقول به سيد
بحذاك واللي يقول به المصف المرزوقي
تحديدا
تعمل خكم خليه كمل خليه وساني ما فيش
دقيقه نجم نجاوبك على ابله هذا مش عنف انت
تمارس في العنف انت تناقش ف فكريا وبالله
يجاوبوا على الدكتور فيصل كي قاللك الحياه
الثقافيه باش المشاهد العربي ما يمشيش في
باله مجله الحياه اللي في لندن شن هي مجله
الحياه الثقافيه الحياه الثقافيه التي
كانت تصدر في عهد بن علي قصدك مش هذا
تصدرها الحكوم الح الثقافيه مجال الحياه
الثقافيه مجاله الحياه الثقافيه مجله
اساسها محمود المسعدي اكبر كاتب محمود
المسعدي بعد ما تحول رس تحريرها لماذا
لاول غيرك لماذا انت بالذات رئيس
تحر كب حر انت قلت كاتب حر ياحسن انت
مضحين قلت انا كاتب حر في هل كنت تكتب
بحريه في الحياه الثقافيه اذا تقرر تكتب
بحريه في الحياه
الثقافيه بس دقيقه طبعا حريه مطلقه وكانت
تنشر الار الامامي وغير الار الامامي
احترم روحك يزيك طيب ماشي كيف ترد على هذا
الكلام كيف ترد اقوللك الرجل الثوره
التونسيه ثوره فريده من نوعها في العالم
الثوره التونسيه حققت كل هذه المكاسب
تخلصت من راس النظام تخلصت من النظام
تخلصت من الحزب الحاكم دو يعني بقليل من
الدماء كانت ثوره يا سمين بكل معنى الكلمه
فلماذا فلماذا انتم تطالبون باجتثاث
الجميع الم تسمع مبسوط يا استاذ حسن يا
حبيبي مبسوط كويس الم تسمع بمقوله لينين
الشهيره اه عندما قال اشكرك اشكرك استاذ
حسن قال لنين بالحرف الواحد قال لنين
بالحرف الواحد لا باس ان نبني النظام
الجديد بحجاره النظام القديم ما العيب حتى
ان يعود بعض ازلام او رموز النظام القديم
للمشاركه في الحياه السياسيه في في تونس
هذا يغني التجربه التونسيه يغني الثوره
التونسيه كيف ترد الاشكال يا استاذ فيصل
هو ان الثوره التونسيه ليست فريده هي ثوره
مشابهه للثورات في التاريخ الثورات في
التاريخ دائما عرف انتكاسات هذا اولا ثم
تعيد انتاج نفسها الثوره فتدافع عن
مؤسساتها وعن قيمها وعن افكارها وعن
مقارباتها وعن احلامها الذي حدث هو ان
الثوره التونسيه نحن لم نطالب فيها
باجتذاب هؤلاء وبالانتقال منهم ولم نطالب
على عكس ما يروجون عد الى تصريح الدكتور
موصى مرزوقي في قناه الجزيره هنا لم يقل
هذا الكلام لم يدعو المرزوقي ل المشانق
كنا متسامحين معهم كانوا يلجؤون الينا بعد
14 جانفي وكنا نقبل نقبلهم وكنا نطالب فقط
باستعاده المال منهب بمحاوله عداله
انتقاليه بالغاء المظ بس انا بدي اسالك
سؤال انت لماذا لا تضع اللوم على الذين
قبلوا الاحزاب الاسلاميه والليبراليه التي
قبلت دقيقه لماذا لا تضع اللوم عليهم
لماذا قبلوا بعوده بالتنافس مع هؤلاء انا
بدي اسالك سؤال عندما تسمح لرموز النظام
القديم بالمشاركه في الحياه السياسيه الا
تعتقد انهم سيتغلبون عليك لاحقا لان لانهم
يعرفون دهاليز الدوله العميقه ودهاليز
السلطه ودهاليز الانتخابات اكثر منك بكثير
هذا الذي حصل طيب ليش تسمحوا لهم بالاصل
انا لم اكن في الحكم انا اقوللك اني انا
وفي للثوره ومدافع عنها لكن انا غير
متقاطع مع الحكومات المتعاقبه على تونس
انا ضد حكومه النهضه وال الترويكا في
خياراتها انا اول من نددت
بتعيينهم لرموز الماضي في مؤسسات الدوله
في وزاره العدل في في المؤسسات العالميه
وفي غيرها انا اقوللك ان الثوره عرفت خيبه
لان من صنفوا على انهم في معسكر الثوره لم
يحموها وهم من خانوا باخطائهم ومن كانوا
واطلقت عباره شهيره مصطلح انتشر كثيرا في
تونس اطلقت عليهم عباره حكومه الايادي
المرتعشه لكن في المقابل لا انا لا اريد
ايادي قاسمه للظهور انا لا اريد مقاسم وفي
نفس الوقت لا اريد ارتخاء اريد ان تتم
عداله انتقاليه تجربه جنوب افريقيا تجربه
احتذى بها تجربه معينه الانصاف والمصالحه
في المغرب في كثير من دول العالم في
البرازيل ماش بس انا بدي اسالك سؤال حتى
لو افترضنا جدلا ان العهد الق
بدا يعود من جديد على البساط الاحمر كما
يقول بعض الناس اه بدا يعود طيب الا تعتقد
ان الشعب التونسي بس دقيقه الا تعتقد ان
الشعب التونسي شعب فريد من نوعه في العالم
العربي ولهذا كانت ثورته فريده من نوعها
الشعب التونسي فريد من نوعه فريد بوعيه
فريد بادراك الشعب التونسي لن يسمح لاحد
ان يستبد من الان فصاعدا كما اعطى الوقت
للنهضه وغيرها بان تحكم لفتره معينه ثم
ازاح عبر صناديق الاقتراع سيفعل نفس الشيء
مع السبسي وغير السبسي فيما لو لم يلبوا
طموحاته الثوريه اولا اريد ان لا اتبنى
عباره ثوره الياسمين هذه لا تمثلنا ول
الثوره نس ليست ثوره الياسمين هي ثوره
حناجر وهي ثوره صدور عاريه وهذه مفرده
مسقطه ثوره الياسمين هي ثوره سيدي بوزيد
وثوره الرقاب وثوره قفصه وثوره حي التضامن
وثوره الكرم والمرسى وثوره فاقس وليست
ثوره الياسمين ثانيا انا اعتقد فعلا فعلا
سيتصدى الشعب التونسي له وسائله البدائل
الشعب التونسي سيكون بامكانه من خلال
مجتمعه المدني من خلال احرار في الصحافه
بعض الاقلام قد تكون مواليه لهذه المنظومه
لكن اغلب الاعلاميين في تونس الان يعون
حجم واجبهم نحو الثوره اغلب الصحفيين في
تونس هم شرفاء والاستثناءات قليله كذلك
اغلب النخب التونسيه نخب الى صالح الثوره
واقفه الى صالح الثوره ولا تفرق بين
علماني وبين اسلامي كذلك نقابتنا كذلك شعب
اعرف هذا لكن حين تكون انت ازاء حكومه
حكومه الترا هذه يمكن لك اسقاطها بالتظاهر
بالصناديق لكن حين تكون امام ديكتاتوريه
حديد ونار كيف ستسقط ستدفع الفواتير من
جديد وستذهب الدماء نحن نريد لكي يثبت هذا
الباجي سبسي وحزبه انه ديمقراطي فليقبل
فليقبل بتعدد القرار وبفكره الرئاسات
الثلاث هذ فكره الرئاسات الثلاث هي التي
حتنا الشعب التونسي جاء وغير حكومته من
خلال الصنديق لان كانت معه مؤسسه هامه
لصالحه المجلس الوطني التاسيسي لان الرئيس
بقي على الحياد ولم يوافق اسال السؤال هذا
ماشي بس الوقت يداهمنا اعود الى السيد حسن
سيد حسن انت من حقك ومن حق كل التونسيين
ومن حق العرب اجمعين ان يفتخروا بان ثوره
تونس حققت اهدافها باقل التكاليف البشريه
والماديه لكن البعض يقول في واقع الامر ان
بروز الدكتاتوريه من جديد على المسرح
سيجعل من التوانسه في الفتره القادمه ان
يتخلوا عن كل سلميتهم وستكون ثوره من نوع
مختلف تماما كيف ترد على الذين يقولون ذلك
والاسلاميون سيخرجون من جحورهم والمتطرفون
بشكل خاص كيف ترد عليهم الوقت
دامنا اوكي اوكي اوكي فيصل سيدي سي فيصل
اسمعني حبيبي تفضل يا سيدي انا يعني ضيفك
اللي في استديو لا يرغب ان تكون ثوره يا
سمين يرغب ان تكون ثوره على فن ورواح نتنه
وكريهه ما تخص اما نحن الحمد لله هذه
الثوره لها ذكر عتر ورا
عح الحمدله الحمدلله سيدي بوزيد هذاك اهل
وناس في سيدي بوزيد يعني لا
تريد خليك راي خليك احترم روحك احترم
روحك حقائق حم حقاق انت الان خليك تم وتدل
انت مساند الباجي وان منرحم النظام خرجتك
مستقل انت غير مستقل الناس تعرفك انت غير
مستقل يا حسن تنكر تاريخك الان انت الناس
تعرفك الان جايبينك في ثوب المستقل ل
تناقش سليم بغر انت لست مستقل قول انت من
اي رحم خرجت من اي نظام والان هذه كلمه
ياسمين انا ضدها لانها السقت ب 7 نوفمبر
87 ثوره ال انا اكره هذه الكلمه ثورت
مفرداتها
وكونا في الاستقلال الاقليه وتونا في حقق
الانسان لعنه الله على هذا النوع من هذا
الموضوع اسمعني خليك خلي اكلم خلي اسمع
فكره اخي لا تسمع
انتل لدرجه ما تسمع تفضل تفضل للاسف تفضل
يا سيدي تفضل كانك مش تسي تفضل على كل حال
انت
يب حال انا اقول انه البلاد هذه البلاد
هذه اسمعني البلاد هذه يا اخويا فيصل تفضل
يا سيدي ستكون ديمقراطيه حاضره للجميع
وفيها الاسلاميين وفيها القوميين وكله
متوس نحن المشكله الذي جاء من البدايه
اراد ان يقسم الشعب التونسي وجعل بين في
الشعب التونسي قال ان ثمه اسلاميين
وعلمانيين قلنا
له العلماني الوحيد هو مسف
المرزوقي
باعترافه و في حركه النهظه له بعدناش نحنا
في تونس كل شعب التونسي مسلم والحمد لله
وهؤلاء هذا النوع منطب يريد ان يشه نار
الفتنه في البلاد ونحن والحمد لله لن نترك
لهم هذا مستحيل يا سليم مظمظ الان نحن
اليوم في انتخابات اليوم تسلم المجلس
الشعب يعني مهامه جديده وقريبا سيكون لنا
رئيس وانت و خطابك التقسيمي والفتن وي
سيذهب الى الجحيم ان شاء الله ونحن نفتخر
باجوار نحبوا الجزائر ونحب المغرب ونحب
ليبيا ونحب ايضا مصر ونحب اهلنا في الخليج
اذا يعني دون ان تشعل الناار ويعني خلينا
نعرف بعضنا نحن خليك يعني في في مقامك
يعني كما ينبغي وخلينا نكون يعني يعني
معقولين يعني جميل جميل جميل
جميل الوطن يريدون يا فيصل ان تكون تونس
مثل سوريا او مثل ليبيا بحذانا او مثل
يعني يعني داعش او شيء من هذا القبيل نحن
قت المصف المرزوقي هذا الرجل جاب دغيش
وجاب ركوبه وجاب يعني
رموز
السلفيه اشكرك جز الشكر للاسف الوقت انتهى
بجمله واحده ما في عندي غير جمله واحده
بانهى الوقت ماذا تقول يا توانسه يا
توانسه نقوللكم عندكم زوز تعرفوهم واحد ما
دخل حد الحبس واحترم الحريات لم ثلاث
سنوات ودافع عنكم لاكثر من 30 سنه من عمره
اسمه الدكتور منص مرزوقي ابن شعبنا وواحد
تعرفوا تاريخه كي كان وزير الداخليه وكي
كان كاتب دوله للامن وكان مدير الامن
الوطني هذاك ما دخل حد الحبس وهذاك يحترم
الديمقراطيه وما يعرش عليكم روح مسم
مرزوقي المرسم المرزوقي عر النظام القديم
حين دافع عنكم لمده سنوات جزيل الشكر
مشاهدينا الكرام لم يبقى لنا نشكر يفينا
هنا في الاستديو السيد سليم بو خضير وعبر
الاقمار الصناعيه من تونس السيد حسن بن
عثمان
حبيبي بتكفي
قال نلتقي
مساء يحييكم من الدوحه الى اللقاء يعطيك
[موسيقى]
العافيه
ه